so Blake you ran for the Senate you did
not win
what's what's different about your
election how did it go you know what was
it well the margin is different you know
I I think I was I I lost by about 125
000 votes was the official difference
between Mark Kelly and me and uh you
know I think I drew a tougher opponent
and and he's an astronaut and man he
nuked me with like 30 or 40 million
dollars right and and uh you know we
thought about suing and and was this you
know was this the right thing to do and
ultimately with all our analysis like no
it wasn't because as messed up as this
election Maricopa was you can't make up
125 000 votes like I don't think I won
the election right now right I have to
have enough Integrity to say that I
can't sell false hope to my people like
I said Abe home a day 500 votes
this stuff in Maricopa County absolutely
swung 500 votes now Kerry has the
interesting in between right 17 000 and
I guess that's that's what her trial was
and she's trying to prove that but for
this incompetence called incompetence at
best malfeasance at worst but for this
incompetence I would have won 17 000
votes we'll see let's let's let's uh
hammer that one down
let's say that Kerry Lake's initial
argument was I understand that it was
one big misunderstanding by everybody
nobody intended to do this improperly
but clearly we can see that the vote
margin could be different if not for all
these tabulators being wrong the law
could not remedy that that's right the
law requires intent it requires intent
and it's not could be different it was
different it would have been different
and that's that's a really hard bar it's
a really hard bar oh that's that's
insane that that's not real governance
real governance is saying okay what do
we know and let's apply remedy on the
facts they're saying regardless of the
facts there's a high standard that must
be met meaning they could the system in
place right now would actually put a
person in power who didn't win I'm
saying hypothetically
just because the standard is too high to
to to to change it
I think it's insane because if I were to
do something like destroy someone's
property but I didn't do it to hurt them
that wasn't my intention my intention
was just like oh I didn't have an
intention I just actually destroyed your
house but I didn't intend to hurt you no
crime yeah apparently when it comes to
the you apply that's of the political
landscape it's not a crime that makes no
sense I mean intention is irrelevant
when you're in talking about somewhat
disrupting and destroying things well
like if you're right somewhat somewhat
if somebody dies and it's no intense
manslaughter it's like if you're
reckless or whatever if you intend to do
it now it's murder but it's still a
crime it is still a crime so potentially
you could be driving in your car and you
could hit somebody and it could be
totally accidental and you don't go to
jail for it so the difference here is
that person still lost their life we
still acknowledge they lost your their
life you maybe still held uh liable
civilly we're talking about an end
process where one person will be the
executive in government in government
meaning there is a very simple remedy if
we can see that something lacks
Integrity in the election we hold a new
election because we're trying to get the
will of the people done right and Kerry
Lake's opponent Katie Hobbs was what was
her Secretary of State of Arizona during
the election her own election I think
even California has a law that bans that
right you shouldn't be able to oversee
an election that you yourself are
running in that's just even even if you
didn't do anything wrong that's just the
appearance of impropriety which is
corrosive to our politics so obviously
Katie Hobbs never should have been
allowed to be Secretary of State and
preside over this election obviously the
Republicans should have spoken out more
about Brian Kemp in Georgia for a
similar reason well it's also important
to note that I think the Republicans
were very divided this upcoming midterm
election we saw a lot of money uh that
was sent in many different places and I
think very surprisingly it was a lot of
democratic super Pacs that were
supporting a lot of the trump-backed
candidates uh but there's also an
article here by uh political that's
describing how Trump was splitting
donations With You Blake 99 2-1 was that
the truth because you were well
overspent uh because your opponent spent
way more money than you can can you just
quickly tell us how much your opponent
spent on how much you spent on on this
upcoming midterm election and where was
their resistance because it seemed like
a lot of old Republicans didn't want to
give you money I have to correct that a
little it's a misleading headline
um it's true in so far as it goes but
actually you know on that list share
president Trump was was sending out
emails saying it done into Blake on my
behalf we were getting those emails it
was helping me grow my email list so the
benefit wasn't Financial in the
immediate term so much as that long-term
list building right he rarely does that
for candidates so it was actually a big
net benefit to me the Press sees that
and they're like oh Trump is screwing
Blake no that wasn't so when someone
donated a hundred dollars you got he got
99 you got a dollar but you also got the
emails from that yep but but and that's
like that's a common that's a common
practice but the media was just looking
to be unfair to Trump on that but so are
you saying that the emails he was
sending out was intended to fundraise
for himself but he included you on it or
was it intended to fundraise for you and
you took the Lion's Share but it still
benefited you more the former more the
former and you'd have to look at the
exact email copy or whatever but like it
was a common practice and they seize on
it right and then yeah so it's like is
that headline accurate technically but
it's misleading by by lack of context
the journalists um they pounced but uh
but yeah but your opponent over here
it's definitely so much more money than
you oh man a lot I so I I worked my tail
off right and I raised 10 million bucks
which is hard to do when the limits are
5 800 so we're raising money you know
phone calls couple hundred bucks at a
time couple thousand bucks at a time
adds up to 10 million uh Mark Kelly
raised about 70 million hard dollars so
it was about seven to one that's on the
hard dollar side and that's the and a
lot of it came from McConnell and the
GOP establishment I'd imagine huh I'm
half kidding by the way I don't think
that definitely didn't help me but but
they you know they sat out what's your
response to the story of democratic
super Pacs financing a lot of the more
populist candidates a lot of the more
trump-backed candidates this mid-term
election because this is one of their
strategies and some people are saying it
actually worked in their favor and there
was Major Democratic organizations
donating to those specific individuals
I'm not sure that happened in Arizona
you know um people thought people
thought that was happening I've heard
that alleged I haven't really seen it
with my own eyes we saw it I think in
Maryland and in New Hampshire as well
um and it and it was like explicit and
overt just because they wanted to run
against balduck or something they yeah
exactly yep they thought it would be an
easier uh it would be easier to get
moderates if they pushed someone that
was you know more conservative or
further right
what uh what'd you spend the 10 million
on is that public uh I think it's public
yeah mostly um I mean mostly you know TV
staff obviously got to cover your costs
and and uh mostly we had volunteer door
knockers and it was a Grassroots lean
operation but uh but staff and then
mostly TV and advertising right TV radio
digital you got to get the message out
did you advertise on social media did we
what did Mark spend 70 million on same
stuff TV he nuked I mean just so August
and September as soon as I won the
Primary I won the Primary August 2nd win
by 12 points wasn't particularly close
August 3rd
the Democrat spigot just turns on right
and everybody is to every third
commercial is just Blake Masters is a
monster Mark Kelly is this great guy
Blake Masters is a Monster who shows you
in black and white yeah yeah exactly
exactly all these but you know I know
we're tempted to think like this stuff
doesn't work this stuff doesn't work
right people can see through it and it's
like well if if you if you go four
months uh and you deploy like 50 million
dollars against somebody telling people
that they're a monster they might
actually believe it on the margin right
which you know what I want to do we were
unable to overcome I would love to run a
commercial like it's too late now but
maybe I'll consider this in the future
where it's just like one of those
campaign ads where it's black and white
it'll be like Mark Kelly went to outer
space how do we know an alien didn't
replace him and then like did he go to
like faster is it a good is a Boy Scout
who helps a church and then that's
basically the formula and it's not
encased and you do that enough and uh
yeah and the ballot harvesting right if
you if you and then they go together
right because I think people are really
paying attention people who have a a
political opinion they're not going to
be I think sold by Those ads but if if
someone just has in their subconscious
while they're trying to watch some
entertainment right Blake Masters is
this horrible guy because I've seen it
36 times in the last two weeks then
someone knocks on the door and says hey
have you filled out that ballot yet no I
haven't I might not oh no hey have you
heard Blake and all of a sudden
there's a there's a vote in the system
by a low propensity voter I just want to
ask you just advertising is quite
effective I just want to ask you one
question just going along with this
conversation what did you learn from
this election and what would you be
doing differently if you could go back
and change anything
going back I think we'd have to focus uh
more on on early voting right harvesting
is technically illegal but there's
nothing illegal about tracking ballots
and actually raising money to go uh it's
almost a bigger project than one
campaign could do but certainly as a
party we need to get better at
understanding we got to be uh banking
votes early I think Carrie Lake and I
you know we we were working hard we
would fill gymnasiums 500 people
thousand people night after night we
were winning hearts and Minds we had the
enthusiasm we had we were look we were
chasing votes and the Dems had turned it
into a mathematical ballot chasing
operation very very early and you know
as soon as voting opened up in October I
think they were able to open up a lead
and so we got to get much more
quantitative and mathematical about it
early on so uh our uh reporter Shane
Cashman he's actually he's covering the
Kerry Lake trial right now very heavily
he had to sit down with Kerry Lake but
he also got to sit down with the a uh
Kanye West who told and he told me he's
like hey man yay's taking ballot
harvesting really really seriously and I
was like that's what that's the one
thing I told him
and I told him uh before the show
started he asked me how do I become
president I was like he asked me three
times and he kept getting mad I wasn't
answering him and I was like because I'm
not a political consultant I was like
okay fine a ballot harvesting and he was
like what's that and I was like knock on
doors tell people to fill out the ballot
have someone fill out the form to
properly return the ballot for them then
it doesn't matter what message you have
you don't need to go to anybody and say
Here's what I'm gonna do all that
matters is you knock on their doors they
just fill it out who cares and they'll
do it and I'm like especially if you're
if you're Kanye West you're not going to
say Trump bite in Kanye West people are
going to say Kanye West celebrity so
some states ballot harvesting is legal
some it's not in 39 States it's illegal
and it's not in Arizona it's not Technic
it's it's illegal in Arizona but here's
how here's here's what is legal right
you can if you have 15 million bucks and
the dumbs do this and Republicans didn't
right to our great detriment but if you
have 15 million bucks you hire a
thousand people you assign each person
here's 500 ballots right people their
names and you can go to their door and
knock hey have you voted we know you got
a mail-in ballot and that person
probably wouldn't have turned it in but
you can just keep bothering them keep
showing it be polite but show up at the
door hey have you voted no hey you want
me to stop coming to your door
vote right now open it up let me walk
you to your mailbox that's legal but you
can't do it and then collect it
physically and then so this is every
state in 39 States you can actually
knock on the door but I'll take it for
you there's just uh in I think it's 12
states have certain stipulations like
you have to sign a form as a caregiver
or something but there are many states
where you're allowed to knock on the
door and be like I'll take that right
for you to the mailbox and then you end
up seeing people coming and dropping off
tons of ballots but but I I'll simplify
it for you someone knocks on the door in
a city
and they say hey I see you got your
mail-in ballot and they go yeah and it
goes why don't you fill it out and they
go
all right I guess who am I voting for
just just Democrat by okay and then what
do I do not just drop it back in the
mailbox right there at the front of your
door and the mailman will come take and
they go okay you're allowed to tell them
to vote Democrat these people are not
politicians who are going back on your
door these are these are activists
non-profits who are just being like as a
regular old person here's what you
should do that sounds like the
government telling Twitter to censor for
them like if just because they're not
politicians they're hired by politicians
to do it I I disagree look if I'm a
regular person and I knock on someone's
door and say I want you to vote for
Blake Masters that's just me as an
individual but if you've been hired by
the Masters campaign to do it it's
different that's very very different but
these are non-profits these are not
these are not the candidates necessarily
doing it to a certain degree they
probably do it to the legal extent they
can but what ends up happening is I
think I think one thing I want to stress
is that a lot of Republicans didn't
understand how Biden could have gotten
so many votes they didn't understand
this going into 2022 even and so we end
up seeing what should have been a red
wave come come in substantially less but
it's not so much that the votes didn't
come in it's that Democrats got a ton of
votes through through ballot harvesting
and Grassroots efforts which is totally
above board and legal except because of
universal mail-in voting laws and
because of absentee voter lists which
persist after the first time you sign up
it makes it extremely easy for urban
centers to get out the vote and very
difficult for Rural voters you are
mentioning that the rural vote didn't
turn out is that what happened not not
how we needed it to in Arizona yeah so
think about you driving out to a rural
area where every house is a football
field away from each other you knock on
the door you wait a few minutes then you
get in your car you drive down the
football field you park you get out you
knock on the door you wait a few minutes
someone answers they say sorry I'm not
interested you get in your car in in a
major urban center where you've got one
big housing unit with a hundred
Apartments you knock on the door no
answer you turn around physically and
knock on the door and you get an answer
A major advantage to Democrats because
they tend to be living in urban areas
Like You could argue it's like thirteen
hundred percent more effective or like
1700 more effective because the amount
of time it takes in a apartment complex
to go to like 190 people it takes you
you probably get to like seven houses in
the country or like nine twelve houses
in the country exactly like a 14 to 1
ratio that's a lot of time and gas money
uh
man and you know we got to be
self-critical some of this was
self-inflicted like Republicans you know
we're we're very into voting in person
on Election Day this cycle right the
good old-fashioned way and like I'm
sympathetic to that I I think you know
more people should vote on Election like
that's that seems like a good thing to
do right this this crazy extension of
mail-in uh voting and that we saw in
kovitz or you know and what what's the
left-wing wish list is just automatic
voter registration uh let's mail a
ballot to everybody 16 year old voters
pretty 16 year old voters pretty soon
they'll say like well let's just presume
that you voted the same way that you did
last time and that you have to opt out
you know I mean that look for that to be
on the the discourse in the next five
years but as long as we have this male
in voting regime we need to we need to
use it let me just say hey don't don't
let the Dems Bank votes and then we'll
all show up on Election Day well on
Election Day the printers might not work
right and you can't leave yourself in
this vulnerable position thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member of over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time